it is ordered adjudged and decreed that  Walter McMillian is to face death by  electrocution it's my dad sir sit down  young man John what you sit down they do  nothing wrong please judge hold on one  second I won't say it again sit down not  even you're gonna kill my dad for no  reason  they convicted an innocent man I was  always taught to fight for the people  who need to help me most you don't know  what it is here they ain't got no  evidence how many of you all were with  Walter that morning  you ain't quit miss no sir we are which  I want my son growing knowing his mom  stopped doing what was right just  because she was scared I think we could  build a case strong enough to bring him  home and I'm not gonna stop until I'm  done man present you deliver  [Applause]  your life is still meaningful and I'm  gonna do everything possible to keep  definitely taking  you